[Música]
Bienvenidos a una semana en el mundo el
programa de France 24 donde los
periodistas son los invitados y
conversamos sobre las noticias que han
marcado la actualidad de la semana en
esta ocasión Vamos a abordar los
intentos de integración de Suramérica y
las divisiones que generan las
relaciones con Venezuela también
abordaremos la convocatoria electoral
anticipada de comicios generales en
España después de que en las elecciones
del pasado domingo arrasar a la derecha
y la extrema derecha Recuerden que
pueden compartir sus opiniones sus
comentarios a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran como arroba
franz24-es o numeral una semana en el
mundo f24 empezamos saludando a nuestros
invitados de hoy nos acompaña aquí en el
estudio Carlos Sanabria él es y de
editor internacional de Radio Nacional
Colombia bienvenido Carlos Gracias
un gusto estar aquí Igualmente Con qué
tema cierra usted esta semana tan movida
cerramos con mucho Movimiento Político
en Colombia rosa con una crisis en el
alto gobierno que implica varios
elementos alrededor de posibles usos
indebidos de los recursos del estado por
un lado y también interceptaciones
ilegales de hecho el presidente Gustavo
Petro durante la jornada ha sido
enfático en decir que su gobierno no
hace ese tipo de actuaciones y se
desmarca de alguna manera del gobierno
anteriores que tuvieron esa sombra Bueno
sí un tema bien bien complejo Marta Moya
la saluda a usted también periodista de
France 24 cronista de revista de prensa
entre muchas otras cuestiones que
desempeñan en esta redacción
internacional Con qué tema cierra usted
la semana Hola Rosa encantada de estar
aquí nuevamente yo creo que un poco de
resaca electoral todavía en España por
las elecciones regionales y locales del
pasado domingo y que vamos a ver cómo se
materializan
el 23 de julio y por otra parte
incertidumbre siempre alrededor de la
guerra en Ucrania con esa contraofensiva
que no llega esos ataques raros y que
todavía no sabemos un poco de dónde
vienen en Moscú entonces todo eso son
los temas con los que acabo y temas que
vamos a abordar aquí en este programa y
saludamos también desde Ciudad de México
a mael Vallejo Él es director editorial
de capital digital mael Muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros le pregunto
también con qué tema cierra usted esta
semana
por la invitación en México lo que está
estamos todos esperando bueno Además del
del anuncio de Taylor Swift viniendo a
América Latina es obviamente las
elecciones en el estado de México que es
el estado más grande del del país y en
donde el partido oficialista Morena se
enfrenta al pri que siempre lo ha
gobernado y que será seguramente un
laboratorio electoral de lo que vendrá
el próximo año en las elecciones
presidenciales pues él es un tema que le
haremos seguimiento aquí en France 24
pero Les propongo empezar abordando
estos intentos de integración en
Suramérica que comentábamos hace unos
instantes porque
esta semana el martes se reunieron en
Brasilia los líderes de América del Sur
convocados por el presidente de Brasil
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva que de este
modo encarnó el regreso de Brasil
precisamente como potencia regional Pero
ese no fue el único retorno se
escenificó en esa reunión Y es que
también supuso precisamente el regreso
de Nicolás maduro el presidente de
Venezuela a la escena internacional
después de no haber asistido a las
pasadas cumbres de la celac la Cumbre de
las Américas o a la Cumbre de la
organización iberoamericana Carlos le
empiezo planteando este tema usted le
sorprendió la presencia de maduro en
Brasil es sorprendente en el entendido
que es muy inusual que el gobierno de
Venezuela le dé la cara a sus colegas
latinoamericanos en este caso a los
colegas suramericanos y aguantar de
alguna manera las diatribas de los
gobiernos como el de chile y como el de
Uruguay de modo que sí había cierta
cierta novedad pero también eso está
marcando un giro en la forma como
Nicolás Maduro se está planteando su
nuevo escenario internacional buscando
quizás más apertura más diálogo De todas
formas ahí hay unos elementos
interesantes que podemos ir mirando
mael le traslado esta pregunta también
para ver cómo cómo lo interpretó a
ustedes de México este regreso de maduro
con a sus compañeros con sus homólogos
de Suramérica
creo que tiene todo que ver con la
llegada de esta ola de gobiernos
izquierdistas a a la región No desde
López Obrador en en México que ya había
invitado a maduro a la celac el año
pasado también con controversias fuertes
por parte de de otros presidentes la
llegada de Petro que también ha sido una
puerta abierta para para maduro y ahora
con con Lula no entonces creo que lo que
se está viendo lo que se está planteando
es eh ante la falta de éxito en las
negociaciones que ha tenido la la
oposición con el gobierno de maduro
también con
las imposiciones de de castigos desde
Estados Unidos pues lo que estamos
viendo ahora es
el intento de poner a maduro de nuevo en
los reflectores y
y buscando una democratización en el
país mal recojo precisamente este
análisis que nos comparte para
trasladarle una cuestión a usted Marta y
es que precisamente no en la región
marcada por el regreso de gobiernos
izquierdistas Gabriel boric es uno de
estos líderes de izquierdas que sin
embargo no comparte la misma posición
que expresó en la presidente de Brasil
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva respecto a la
situación en Venezuela no recordemos que
Lula habló de un problema de narrativas
y borich dijo que no era cuestión
solamente de una narrativa sino de una
realidad muy concreta Cómo analiza usted
estas discrepancias entre líderes de
izquierdas respecto a la situación en
Venezuela Pues sí Rosa parece que entre
los líderes izquierdistas de América
Latina siempre Gabriel boric es esa nota
un poco más discordante no él leía
también una columna en un medio
brasileño que decían que era un poco el
rehén de la derecha todo por la
situación interna que tiene Gabriel
boric en chile y estas distensiones yo
creo que son totalmente naturales en un
gobierno que en una región que al final
es muy heterogénea Es verdad que ahora
estamos viviendo una ola de gobiernos
izquierdistas pero cada gobierno y cada
país tiene sus particularidades Y eso
también por ejemplo en la guerra en
Ucrania no los países Sí hay una
posición común en no enviar armas pero
cada quien aporta sus matices Gabriel
bori que es el único líder Regional de
izquierda que por ejemplo se ha
mantenido firme en condenar la agresión
rusa a Ucrania Pero esto también Bueno
pues afecta a otros foros también
regionales y estas distensiones y estas
de críticas y bueno todos estos puntos
de vista al final suman y nutren un poco
a la región que no tiene un único punto
de vista y entonces yo creo que todo
esto suma que la integración de
Venezuela al final es una buena noticia
o es el camino hacia una buena noticia
Porque eso significa que al final Bueno
pues es una región más integradora y que
Venezuela también ha reconocido algunos
errores que ha cometido en el pasado
también a escala regional si Marta
precisamente antes de trasladarle esta
cuestión creo que la columna la que
usted se refiere es publicada en la fue
de Sao Paulo una columna de Mónica
bergamo titulada el gobierno de Lula
como un rehén de la derecha y a Chile
como un ejemplo a evitar no precisamente
pues le traslado esta pregunta veía que
usted estaba sintiendo al comentario de
Marta comparte este análisis Sí sí lo
comparto pero aquí hay que decir una
cosa quizás la gran figura hoy de
América Latina y que de alguna forma
separa frente a diferentes escenarios de
la política internacional ese presidente
Lula Silva y sin Lula Silva lo que
ocurrió esta semana en Brasilia no
hubiera sido posible ha sido él el
garante para que Nicolás Maduro llegara
a Brasilia que saliera de Caracas porque
recordemos en enero el presidente de la
celac había un riesgo de una posible
captura estaba el precedente de este
avión venezolano iraní que detuvieron
allí que luego llegó el departamento de
Justicia bueno toda esas situaciones
asombra le impedía maduro llegar a
Buenos Aires no era un terreno fácil
para él porque hay de todas formas
abierto contra Nicolás Maduro una
búsqueda y ahí Incluso un apellido de
recompensa muy alto entonces Lula es el
el garante de que maduro llegue Pero
además el presidente de Colombia Gustavo
Petro y el mismo maduro lo reconoce Así
es el garante del diálogo político de
Venezuela con la región y con la
oposición de hecho maduro dice vienen un
grupo de cancilleres en esta semanas
vamos a hablar me traen un mensaje y
veremos a ver qué sucede para que esto
no quede en La retórica sino que vaya a
lo que puntualmente están buscando los
venezolanos primero que se resuelva su
crisis económica de acá y política y
social y que se convoquen las elecciones
para el próximo año efectivamente en
relación a esta convocatoria de
elecciones previstas para el próximo año
y a los diálogos entre la oposición y el
oficialismo de Venezuela mael le
trasladó a usted Cuál es el próximo paso
que debe dar a Venezuela para digamos
que se materialicen estas elecciones y
también Cuál es el papel ahí de Estados
Unidos no porque parece que es un poco
un pez que se muerde la cola que unos y
también la Unión Europea van a levantar
sanciones si se convoca en elecciones y
los otros van a convocar elecciones si
se levantan sanciones
claro ha sido un proceso muy complicado
hay que entender también que en enero
Dejó de ser el presidente legítimo
avalado por más de 50 países de
Venezuela y que a partir de eso la
oposición venezolana está en un lugar
muy complicado no en los diálogos en
México se mantienen y ya hay un avance
en poder hablar de del levantamiento de
no de sanciones pero si al menos de
abrir el capital venezolano que que está
blindado para que pueda ser utilizado
por el por el gobierno lo cual
seguramente será un primer paso sin
embargo Son son indicios que ya hemos
visto antes no son como pequeño pequeños
pasos que parece que que se dan y y que
van a llegar a un punto de Concordia O
al menos de de diálogo entre la
oposición y el gobierno de maduro y que
al final alguna de las dos partes
siempre acaba levantándose de la mesa
creo que con el apoyo ahora de de Petro
con lo que está haciendo Lula Eh Pues
también eso abre un panorama muy
distinto no
también a Estados Unidos que tampoco ha
logrado con estas sanciones lo que ha
querido eh maduro siguen el poder sigue
sin haber elecciones libres y creo que
este este año este proceso que se abre
no solamente con Venezuela sino a nivel
regional va a ser muy interesante para
poder tener por fin unas elecciones
democráticas con observadores
internacionales el próximo año Marta
como como le debe usted cómo ve esta
perspectiva Bueno yo creo que al final
todo esto son pasos adelante para que
maduro recupere un poco esa imagen
también de cara al exterior no ya lo
hemos visto mucho en estos meses cuando
la guerra en Ucrania ha afectado mucho a
las posiciones de maduro en este nuevo
planteamiento en la escena internacional
no al final
Venezuela tiene una dependencia rusa
sobre todo a nivel político y económico
y Estados Unidos no se quería perder
tampoco su papel no su cuota de poder en
toda esta negociación y en toda esta
situación Entonces ha planteado vamos a
revisar las sanciones a cambio de que
haya elecciones libres vamos a dar pasos
ha habido reuniones de alto nivel en
Caracas y enviados de Washington a la
capital Venezolana en los últimos meses
entonces todos estos son pasos que
evidentemente cooperan para que
Venezuela eventualmente pues vuelva un
poco a la escena pero con unas garantías
de no repetición de los errores que se
han cometido a los en estos últimos años
y Carlos no quisiera cerrar este tema
sin hablar de los ámbitos además de la
cuestión de Venezuela en los que puede
cooperar precisamente Suramérica no
hablamos de medio ambiente economía
seguridad claro y es que lamentablemente
los últimos años la ideologización de
del bloque regional suramericano la oea
la celac todos esos elementos por la
presencia de bloques cercanos a Nicolás
Maduro como el de Nicaragua como Cuba
gobier que están alineados allí en la
misma Bolivia ya no tanto pero en su
momento con la presencia de de Evo
Morales sí hacían que esos grandes temas
globales no estén sobre la mesa y eso
quizás uno de los triunfos de Lula da
Silva al llevarlos a Brasil a todos
estos mandatarios les dice es necesario
que hablemos de energías limpias es
necesario que hablemos de agua es
necesario que hablemos de cambio
climático de infraestructura y zonas que
todavía en Sudamérica no pasa un tren no
pasa una carretera y se necesita el
concurso de las Naciones enfocados en
objetivos puntuales y bien definidos en
momentos de desaceleración económica
donde todavía la guerra en Ucrania está
pesando mucho en las economías todos
estos elementos geopolíticos son
necesarios que se han afrontados por
Suramérica en bloque pero estar
ideologizados entre los que quieren a
maduro en las cumbres y entre los que no
quieren o entre los que van y no van
porque está uno o el otro Pues es lo que
ha impedido que esos diálogos avancen y
a corto plazo le hago usted esta última
pregunta para cerrar este bloque a corto
plazo Cuál es el reto más inmediato en
el que vamos a ver esta cooperación
efectiva suramericana
los diales me parecen los diálogos en
México estos diálogos en México entre la
oposición y el gobierno de maduro tienen
que avanzar han tenido muchos impases no
han logrado en realidad llegar a ningún
acuerdo y de nuevo volviendo a ocho
punto en el cual con el concurso de Lula
con el de Petro el de otros líderes de
de la región pues probablemente podamos
ver un un avance pero me parece en este
momento lo lo más importante lo lo
fundamental el que estos diálogos pueda
puedan avanzar el que cada uno de los de
los lados seda un poco para poder
empezar a a llegar a acuerdos sino
parece que falta mucho tiempo pero en
realidad son pocos meses y lo que hemos
visto en los últimos años ha sido este
nivel de de congelamiento y que ninguno
de los dos lados cede para poder llegar
a acuerdos que que logren de nuevo
democratizar a un país que lleva mucho
tiempo sin él Bueno pues veremos cómo
avanza esta integración suramericana Y
seguramente vamos a ver si se trata de
esta voluntad de integración o de una
sintonía ideológica cuando se conozcan
los resultados de las elecciones en
Argentina no que pueden decantar
muchísimo La balanza hacia un lado o
hacia el otro vamos a hablar ahora
también de elecciones pero vamos a
cambiar de continente y vamos a España
porque ahí después de que la derecha y
la extrema derecha la derecha del
partido popular y la extrema derecha de
vox arrasarán en los comicios
municipales y regionales del pasado
domingo el presidente del gobierno
español El socialista Pedro Sánchez tomó
la decisión de convocar elecciones
anticipadas para el próximo 23 de Julio
elecciones generales es decir elecciones
que van a determinar el próximo gobierno
de España Antes de hablar aquí de su
reacciones a estos comicios a este
anuncios no de los comicios anticipados
Les propongo que veamos Cuáles fueron
las reacciones de nuestros compañeros
españoles de los periodistas de varios a
medios de comunicación de España porque
sin duda esta convocatoria tomó por
sorpresa a todo el país veamos de forma
que los comicios se celebrarán el
domingo 23 de julio de acuerdo con los
plazos que establece la ley
la convocatoria formal de las elecciones
aparecerá publicada mañana martes el
boletín oficial del estado de forma que
los comicios se celebrarán el domingo 23
de celebrarán el domingo 23 de julio de
acuerdo con los plazos que establece la
ley
Marta ahora empiezo por usted le
sorprendió de igual manera esta
convocatoria Bueno un poco sí la verdad
porque los comicios estaban planteados
para el mes de diciembre Entonces es un
adelanto electoral sustancial pero yo
creo que Pedro Sánchez quiso es un poco
mitigar los daños del resultado de las
elecciones locales y regionales y que no
se hablara tanto de la derrota del
partido socialista sino que se hablara
de que ya hay otra Campaña en marcha
para el mes de julio me sorprendió Claro
Por qué pues se solapan las campañas y
al final no hay un respiro ni siquiera
para el electorado es una fecha un poco
también controvertida porque estamos en
plena época estival mucha gente se va de
vacaciones veremos a ver si esto pues
logra disuadir a mucho electorado o no
Si el voto por correo Se multiplican
estas elecciones Yo creo que es una
fecha bueno complicada Por una parte
pero que también puede sacarle un poco
de rédito el partido socialista porque
ponen el foco la nueva campaña y puede
hacer una campaña más agresiva contra la
derecha y la extrema derecha sobre todo
Una vez que ha perdido las elecciones
locales y regionales no Entonces ese
relato Pues ahora lo tienen más a favor
el partido socialista y puede hacer eso
una campaña mucho más incisiva de cara
julio vamos a hablar ahora de esta
campaña ya pero antes para dar a nuestra
audiencia un poco de contexto en cifras
recordemos que en estas elecciones
municipales del pasado domingo 28 de
mayo el partido popular la derecha
tradicional en España sumó más de 7
millones de votos frente a los 6,3 del
partido socialista esto es un gran
cambio Respecto a los comicios
municipales de 2019 Cuando el partido
Popular en aquel momento sumó 5,2
millones de votos casi dos millones
menos y el partido socialista fue en ese
momento la fuerza más votada con 6,7
millones de votos y la participación Fue
bastante alta prácticamente el 64% de
las personas convocadas a ir a personas
efectivamente acudieron a ellas Bien le
traslado la pregunta Carlos cómo vio
usted este auge de la derecha y de la
extrema derecha en estas elecciones como
un voto de castigo al gobierno de Pedro
Sánchez y ese alguna de alguna manera
Rosa la tendencia también en Europa
después de lo que pasó en Italia con
Georgia melón y comienzan entonces a
marcarse estos puntos de diferencia yo
quisiera enfocarme quizás en el hecho de
que va a ser el fin del sanchismos Y es
que eso existe en España por lo menos La
era de Pedro Sánchez en el gobierno que
toma una decisión muy Audaz de de ir
hacia adelante hacer una huida hacia
adelante en materia política y Buscar
que el partido popular no piense tanto
no dejarlo pensar porque particularmente
las elecciones en España me corregirán
ustedes octubre noviembre a finales de
los años cuando vienen esas elecciones
darle ese margen de estrategia
pensamiento al partido popular pues se
le iba a venir en contra entonces muy
arriesgado muy Audaz hay riesgos
electorales varios medios de
comunicación y columnistas plantean
sobre qué podría pasar con un voto tan
masivo por correo y lo otro el partido
popular si es que gana las elecciones
generales de alguna forma tendrá que
pactar con vox y Box sabe lo sabe y se
va a posicionar como ese partido en el
que van a venir políticas duras y donde
van a venir cosas importantes de modo
que va a ser bien bien interesante esa
ese movimiento de la política española
en estos dos meses y precisamente esta
ambivalencia que usted comentaba no como
el presidente del gobierno el socialista
Pedro Sánchez no quiere dar mucho tiempo
tampoco a la derecha para tomar el poder
efectivo no y llegar a ese a esa campaña
de desgaste del gobierno digamos en
general Pero por otro lado también puede
aprovechar la derecha tradicional
partido popular que el margen es tan
corto entre estas los resultados de las
elecciones regionales y municipales y la
convocatoria de las elecciones generales
para intentar no llegar a pactos con la
extrema derecha ahí donde los necesitan
en las ciudades y en las regiones donde
los necesitan antes de las nuevas
elecciones para precisamente intentar
distanciarse todavía de la extrema
derecha y no que no salgan fotos no
dándose la mano en acuerdos de gobierno
bien le trasladó mael esa pregunta
también a usted desde México le
sorprendió este auge de la extrema
derecha que fue bueno ganó subió en
todas las provincias de España
claro creo que como como bien decía
Carlos no me parece sorpresivo pero sí
me parece que hay un parteaguas en este
momento no que con este auge de box pero
también con la desaparición de
ciudadanos con podemos en la lona es
decir este bipartidismo que durante
mucho tiempo estuvo en la política
Española y que de pronto se abrió a
fuerzas no es decir al menos había como
muchas más posibilidades en este momento
este
negociando con el con el PP con todos
los problemas que puede traer Es cierto
que te está esto pasando en gran parte
de Europa pero también y trasladándolo
hasta este hasta este lado se del
Atlántico Habría que ver
y fijarnos muy bien en lo que está
sucediendo en España y cuál es el camino
que que podría pasar acá no También
tenemos a Javier Miley en Argentina a
José Antonio kast en Chile es decir este
auge del extrema derecha Parece ser no
solamente en Europa sino también desde
este desde este lado
en esta región y creo que habría que
poner muchos ojos en este crecimiento
que como tú dices a mí sí me parece un
es un voto de castigo para para el
gobierno del psoe y que estos votos de
castigo lo que han hecho ha sido tener
allá y bolsonaro presidente en Brasil a
en Italia y ni hablemos de lo que ha
sucedido en Austria lo que está pasando
en Francia es decir hay un auge en todas
las regiones y tendríamos que poner
mucho ojo en ello Ismael precisamente
muy interesante esta traslación a la
situación en otros países Marta le
quiero plantear sin embargo la política
más popular de España es la ministra de
trabajo y vicepresidenta del gobierno
Yolanda Díaz que lanza su propia
plataforma la que Espera que se sumen a
todos los partidos que están a la
izquierda del partido socialista
incluido podemos que ha desaparecido
prácticamente del mapa en estas
elecciones municipales y regionales no
ha entrado a regiones o a ciudades tan
importantes como Madrid Ella es la
responsable recordemos de reformas la
ahora mismo el paro en España está al
nivel más bajo desde 2008 también en
cinco años este gobierno ha hecho que el
salario mínimo pasara de 735 euros a
1080 en los que están estos momentos
Cómo puede servir esta este liderazgo de
la ministra de trabajo para movilizar a
la izquierda en España Bueno yo creo que
Yolanda Díaz tiene un reto grande por
delante que es unificar a la izquierda
que esto es uno de los grandes males de
España bueno históricos no Porque
mientras la derecha va muy unida siempre
la fragmentación de la izquierda al
final siempre la acaba jugando malas
pasadas ahora tenemos el ejemplo ya muy
claro y muy notorio de que o hay una
Unión o es posible que se redite no esta
Victoria electoral del partido popular e
incluso de vox en las elecciones
generales de Julio por tanto Yolanda
Díaz tiene el reto de decirle a podemos
que ella es la candidata que puede
catalizar esas bueno esas frustraciones
de la izquierda que evidentemente se
niega a a un partido que sea más allá
del psoe y que por supuesto no quiere
que llegue a la presidencia del gobierno
un candidato como Alberto Núñez cejo que
es el candidato del partido popular e
incluso y que llega a las instituciones
un partido Como vox de ultraderecha que
ponen jaque muchos de los principios
democráticos de España entonces Yolanda
Díaz tiene ese reto y yo creo que se va
en estos días a materializar esa
coalición para el 23 de Julio si Marta
todo apunta a que se va a materializar
esta coalición por los comentarios que
han hechos los distintos líderes de la
izquierda pero Precisamente en un
momento en que parece que el eje
discursivo de la derecha en España se ha
radicalizado hacia la extrema derecha no
tenemos figuras tan importantes como la
presidenta de la región de Madrid
Ayuso no que es muy radical dentro de su
propio partido y en un momento en que
vox crece Y se normaliza cree que va a
funcionar esta estrategia de alertar de
nuevo que es este gobierno o la extrema
derecha y de hacer movilizar el voto
frente al miedo de la extrema derecha
por lo menos hay que intentarlo porque
yo creo que ante un discurso tan
radicalizado de la derecha Isabel Ayuso
la presidenta de la comunidad de Madrid
decía el domingo que era votarle a ella
o votar a eta no que es este grupo
terrorista ya extinto en el país Vasco
en esta región del norte de España
entonces ante un discurso tan
radicalizado y mientras esta señora
Isabel Díaz Ayuso consigue una mayoría
absolutísima en la comunidad de Madrid
hay que poner siempre y hacer el énfasis
por parte de la izquierda yo creo en que
estos discursos solo llevan a la
polarización a la confrontación y que
hay combatir también estas mentiras no
porque al final eta se disolvió el
partido que recogió todo ese esa
voluntad política es H bildu que es un
partido de la izquierda independentista
totalmente legal en España Entonces yo
creo que la izquierda tiene que hacer
más énfasis de que no sea la izquierda o
el caos simplemente de todas las
advertencias todo lo que está en jaque
si llega un partido de ultraderecha al
gobierno de España como Xbox y Marta
aprovecho rápidamente su conocimiento en
detalle de la actualidad española para
plantearle ya dicho vox y ha dicho el
partido popular que si llegan al
gobierno van a acabar con las bueno van
a derogar la legado de este gobierno de
izquierdas como serían la ley de memoria
histórica la ley trans la ley de la
eutanasia las reformas económicas Por
qué cree que hay un electorado en el
país que no está de acuerdo no está
preparado para este progresismo que ha
encarnado este gobierno yo creo que sí
no porque al final el país está
enormemente polarizado y efectivamente
Pues hay una parte de España que
considera que todo lo que ha hecho el
gobierno de Pedro Sánchez con unidas
podemos ha sido en detrimento del
bienestar o de los propios españoles No
ese proteccionismo ese auge no de la
españolidad pues lo han encarnado PP y
vox durante todos estos años y yo creo
que hay una parte de España que ha
creído ese discurso leía esta mañana un
análisis de Guardian del británico de
Guardian que decía un poco que Europa
Espera que la estrategia de Sánchez
funcione no
Y para que se mantengan todo no todas
estas políticas progresistas que ha
impulsado el gobierno progresista en
España y que al final fundamentan un
poco ese estado del bienestar en materia
social y económica principalmente
Exactamente Bueno veremos también como
la pandemia la inflación global ha
pasado factura a este gobierno
independientemente de su signo político
Les propongo ahora también un comentario
rápido sobre otro de los temas que han
marcado la actualidad de la semana mael
voy con usted y sobre vamos al Salvador
porque nayib bukele este jueves 1 de
junio cumplió cuatro años en el poder y
esto en medio de la polémica por su
eventual presentación a la reelección a
pesar de precisamente la controversia
que hay sobre las interpretaciones
constitucionales de esta posibilidad y
siendo un líder que por un lado desata
pasiones tiene cuenta con el
nueve de cada diez ciudadanos de El
Salvador aprueban su gestión mientras
que por otro lado la comunidad
internacional lo critica por la esa
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos en
el marco de su estado de excepción que
ya cumple un año y más de dos meses en
el marco de su guerra contra las
pandillas Cómo se entiende esta
dicotomía
Claro pero hay que entender que El
Salvador viene de de décadas de
muchísima violencia no con con las
pandillas y que la población en este
momento creo que ya no le importa la
forma en la que en la que se contenga
esta violencia sino más bien está
aplaudiendo lo que ha hecho bukele sin
embargo Me parece muy peligroso también
porque todo lo que ha hecho el
presidente ha sido este gobierno
unipersonal donde ya tiene solamente el
poder ejecutivo sino también el
legislativo El Judicial es decir ha
optado eh A todo lo los poderes tiene
este estado de excepción desde hace
meses violando derechos humanos y creo
que lo siguiente pasos y lo que podemos
ver ahí es un reflejo de lo que ha
sucedido en Nicaragua en Cuba en
Venezuela es decir
se va a presentar a una reelección que
es algo que ya ha dicho aunque sea
anticonstitucional Pero bueno la suprema
corte le pertenece también al igual que
que el poder legislativo Entonces no
tiene ningún contrapeso ya del lado
periodístico o de ong no es decir ha
habido un un cerco a todo todo la la
oposición y ahora lo que vamos a ver es
cómo se consolida en el poder y después
de eso va a ser muy complicado
seguramente eh sacar a bukele del de la
presidencia y Carlos le traslado esta
misma pregunta usted cómo entiende usted
esta esta dicotomía y como él que prevé
en un futuro a corto plazo claro hay dos
visiones claramente definidas en el
asunto del Salvador una la interna y
pues aquí el nuestro compañero planteado
Precisamente es una cosa es como la
están viviendo los ciudadanos azotados
por tantos años de violencia que con
razón aprueban este tipo de medidas de
mano fuerte la comunidad internacional
por otro lado la visión de lo que
debiera ser en circunstancias quizás más
controladas pero lo que estaba
sucediendo en El Salvador no no era
controlado sin embargo si hay dudas del
debido proceso si hay dudas de la manera
como es encarcelada la gente cuando la
logran de tener si puede controlar el
estado y la seguridad de esas personas
esta semana veíamos un reporte que nos
indicaba 153 muertes de personas bajo
custodia del estado en medio del régimen
de excepción que ya lleva más de más de
un año pero también bukele lo tiene
claro y dijo voy por los pandilleros y
ya metió a la cárcel a 69.000 ahora dijo
voy por los corruptos entonces ahí
también es un campanazo para la clase
política para los empresarios que quizás
adversan dentro del Salvador para
Incluso el comercio internacional todo
eso es elementos están llevando y lo que
están mostrando es que bukele se está
haciendo un camino en el cual esa lucha
contra la corrupción le va a terminar
dando mucho más poder del que ya hoy
tiene y Marta no quiero cerrar este
programa traslado directamente a usted
otro tema que sé que ha cubierto esta
semana y son los ataques sobre Moscú
como la guerra en Ucrania se estaría
trasladando a territorio ruso como
analiza Esta bueno este giro en los
acontecimientos pues Rosa un giro que no
vimos venir mucho porque sobre todo uno
de los planteamientos claros de
occidente cuando dotaba o cuando está
dotando de armas a Ucrania era que no
penetrara en territorio ruso no sino que
utilizar ese armamento para defenderse
hay que ver De dónde proceden esos
ataques todavía es bastante una
incógnita todo pero sí que hay reportes
de que Ucrania podría estar detrás de
todo esto no los servicios de
inteligencia eso sí traslada una cosa
muy clara a los rusos Y es que la guerra
Ya está en su territorio entonces hay
que ver Todavía ahora el kremlin como
plantea esta estrategia futuro de
momento la respuesta del gobierno ruso
ha sido bastante tibia ha habido como
muchas amenazas pero no se ha acabado de
materializar han caído esta semana
cientos de misiles sobre kiev pero no ha
habido un movimiento mucho más allá yo
creo que a la espera también de lo que
vaya a pasar en esta contraofensiva se
están reservando también las fuerzas los
rusos pero lo que traslada es esto no la
guerra ha llegado a Rusia que va a hacer
el gobierno ruso para defenderse de lo
que ellos dicen ya es una agresión
contra ellos Bueno pues se nos acaba el
tiempo para continuar comentando la
actualidad de la semana que ha estado
bien cargada les pregunto rápidamente
para cerrar este programa Con qué tema
ponen en qué tema ponen la mirada de
cara la semana que viene pues yo me
quedo con este mismo tema Cómo va a ir
avanzando este tema de la guerra en
Ucrania porque cada vez se suman más
ingredientes y más incertidumbre de lo
que va a ocurrir en los próximos meses
Rosa Carlos ponerle el ojo a la
situación de violencia en Ecuador con el
asesinato de un fiscal en la ciudad de
urana y muy cerca de Guayaquil las
amenazas a la fiscal general en el
contexto de de una crisis política de
alguna manera de la falta de contrapesos
en Ecuador y que respecto a la noticia
que usted nos comentaba al inicio hemos
tenido una pequeña actualización
mientras ha durado Este programa Así es
el presidente Gustavo Petro retira de su
cargo al embajador en Venezuela Armando
Benedetti y a su jefe de gabinete la
secretaría privada Laura Sarabia en una
historia que nos abarcaría un programa
completo pero que involucra
interceptaciones ilegales abuso y de
recursos del Estado hasta una niñera
entonces lo que tiene que hacer es verlo
aquí en France 24 Exacto Sí sí le hemos
dado cobertura más rápidamente usted
Sí por supuesto el tema de Petro y aquí
en México volviendo hay que ver Cuáles
son los resultados de las elecciones
locales en el estado de México que serán
muy importantes para las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo año el
gobierno de López Obrador se juega una
gran parte de su capital político en lo
que suceda este domingo en el Estado de
México Bueno pues llegamos así al final
de este programa muchísimo gracias a los
tres Muchísimas gracias a ustedes por su
atención y a nuestro equipo de
producción y a nuestro equipo técnico
para hacer posible Este programa sigan
con nosotros con más información